hey youtubers is Charlie so big
emergency there are for Game of Thrones
spin-offs and development right now so
I'll try to explain what all that means
of what they might be I think that means
Game of Thrones just one Star Wars day
unless there's some surprise trailer
that's going to drop so new round of the
game of Thrones giveaway because this is
such awesome news all yesa did to enter
is be a subscriber leave a comment on
this video it's for one of the enhanced
editions of the books so the most
important stuff there are four separate
spin-offs that are in development right
now at the same time george RR martin is
only personally involved with two of
those they've announced all the
different people that are writing these
ideas but let's focus on the to the
George R Martin are attached to right
now and I'll explain the others too
because what HBO is doing is is taking
the Star Wars story group approach to
developing ideas so when they're talking
about Star Wars movies that they want to
do they don't talk about one movie at a
time they marvel Warner Brothers the big
comic book movie studios they developed
several ideas all at the same time all
year round is always hundreds of ideas
that never make it past the idea stage
but whatever HBO was considering for
their spinoff they've whittled it down
to four that are being written that
doesn't mean that there's going to be
four different Game of Thrones shows
running at the same time one of them
will probably start the next season
after Game of Thrones Season eight ends
so if this is season 7 this year 2018
season eight then 2019 would probably be
when the spin-off would start depending
on when they start production but they
just want to get the ball rolling and
there was a writer strike that almost
happened which is probably why you're
hearing about this right now
otherwise they probably would have sat
on this news and just waited till way
later to announce it but what are the
two shows the George R Martin is working
on so there are two big anthology
stories that he's written that they
haven't touched in Game of Thrones yet
that's probably what he's attached to
because of all the Song of Ice and Fire
material he spent the most time with the
actual stuff that he's been writing so
one is the tales of duncan egg it's an
anthology series that takes place a
little less than a hundred years before
the events that are happening on the TV
show right now but it follows Aegon v
egg in Duncan the tall so you have egg
as an egg on because he had a bald head
so his brothers called him egg for short
you know that Maester Aemon
the wall called his name before he died
he was one of eggs brothers that's how
old Maester Aemon was dunk is sir Duncan
the tall
he's an ancestor of Brienne of Tarth
that's why she's so tall because he was
huge so that runs in her family there
are three books that Martin has already
written as part of that series and
affords his plan there's the hedge
Knight two sworn sword the mystery
Knight and then the fourth one is called
the she-wolves of Winterfell and he's
not going to write that till after he's
done with winds of winter so it's not
going to drop for a while but those are
novellas they're not like full novels
like Song of Ice and Fire novels so it's
less material but he spent a lot of time
developing those characters the other
spin-off idea he might be attached to is
the dance of the Dragons conflict it
takes place before the events of Duncan
egg and it's basically a Targaryen Civil
War now it's not the Blackfyre rebellion
but is a war of succession fought within
the Targaryen family in a time when
dragons proliferated so if you're a big
fan of dragons on Game of Thrones
that would be your spin up and I think
they're trying to do a spin up that
feels familiar while at the same time
being is different from the narrative
that you're seeing right now but there
are a couple of other huge events that
would be very popular that they could do
there's Robert's rebellion a really big
event that they briefly touched on but
Dan and Dave have already created the
framework for the events of that series
I don't think that George R Martin would
be developing that specifically he's
probably mostly working on the series
that are very different than what
they've done before the thing that he's
usually there for is to help them with
the characters so they're doing
unfamiliar characters the series hasn't
already touched on like young Ned Stark
young Robert Baratheon young Lyanna
Stark that's where all these new riders
would need the most help
so Robert's rebellion is a really easy
idea you could even bring back some of
the actors like Arthur Dayne Eiling
Frankie OC to play Leon a start because
she's about the right age and it's a
really interesting event and you could
call it Game of Thrones rebellion I
think it's key that they keep the
spin-off title as short as possible in a
really big idea in the world now in real
world politics is rebelling against
oppressive leaders so Game of Thrones
rebellion feels like a timely series
even though it's not that much different
than stuff that we've seen before but
the other really key thing I think
that's important for the spin-off that
they do is they want to do something
that people
aren't super familiar with the main
series maybe they haven't even watched a
Game of Thrones episode before could
pick it up and run with it so there are
a lot of things as book readers that we
know about big historical events that
are way less familiar and I think they
want to keep it as familiar as possible
well at the same time being able to
focus on different characters so it's
like oh you know baby Jon Snow we know
him because we just spent the last seven
seasons watching him but here's his
mother somebody that we only learned a
little bit about she's actually a really
fascinating character by herself - we'd
be able to see Rhaegar Targaryen another
character that people have only talked
about in cryptic ways so the most
exciting thing beyond that obviously R +
L equals J people go crazy about that
but there's young Robert Baratheon so
you've seen the old man that's gone to
see the terrible leader really during
season one he's a sad version of himself
you would get to see the warrior the
conquering Robert Baratheon the badass
the ones that everybody told to be King
even though they knew he was wildly
unqualified there are a couple other
really big events that are super
familiar like Aegon's conquest they
could do a history of the Targaryen
family centered on Aegon the conquerer
so you could do the doom of Valyria you
could do Danice the dreamer in the story
of how his family came to live at
Dragonstone then he conquered the Seven
Kingdoms you could stretch that out for
seven seasons and I should have made
this clear to all these spin-off ideas
would be like 70 hour ideas so anytime
they develop a big show like this they
want to make sure that it can run for
seven seasons so this could change but
as far as they've explained each of
these four separate ideas would be full
blown series there be ten episodes of
season and there'd be at least seven
seasons and because Game of Thrones is
ten times as popular as any other series
that HBO has ever done even if it's not
as popular as the main series anything
they do could make it easily two seven
seasons so beyond those really easy
picks those are the easy slam dunks that
would also be very different from what's
happening now although Aegon's conquest
does feel a little bit similar to
Daenerys because there's so many
parallels between her life and his life
but I just love the idea of them doing a
Game of Thrones series where they just
called it Game of Thrones conquest and
whatever they do it will probably be
called Game of Thrones with a subtitle
Game of Thrones dot something but what
about that last pick they're also
probably considering a sequel series
that would take place after what's
happening on the show now so that
characters from the show that survived
through season eight could just come and
get star every once in a while but they
wouldn't have to be main characters so I
know that sounds kind of lame it's the
easiest thing that they could possibly
do it would just be sit like a couple
years after what's happening on the show
now and you would follow King Jon Snow
if he survives season eight we got to
talk about theories of how the series is
going to end because if they do want to
do a sequel series it would probably
have to be about one of the biggest
characters right now like you've heard
about all the actors earning crazy money
for season eight that's why I'm feeling
that they probably won't do a sequel
series because they would have to do a
big character who's already earning
crazy money and it would just destroy
the show's budget so I think they want
to stick with familiar house names so
you have like House Stark House
Lannister but there'll be new actors
playing characters and it's just easier
to do that as a prequel series they
could do the origin of those great
houses which is set way back in the Age
of Heroes so it would be set a long time
like thousands and thousands of years
before what's happening on the show
right now in thematically it's usually
important to tie them to a big event
like the dance of the Dragons is this
huge conflict within the Targaryen
family and if they're doing the war for
the dawn on the main series right now
what is the other really big event that
people are already familiar with in
history so another really easy idea
would be to start a series set as
they're building the wall which on the
show would be about a thousand years
before what's happening right now but in
the books it's closer to eight thousand
years so you would actually see brand
the builder and you could also jump
forward to the rise of the Valyrian
freehold so I think what they want to do
is they want to do a spin-off series
that allows them to go to the east and
travel around to a lot of familiar
places they don't want to just be stuck
in Westeros or just stuck in the East if
you've read the books you know that
there's this grand history they could do
any number of events and it would be
really cool they can go to a shy and do
a series set over there that had nothing
to do with what was going on in Westeros
and that would be badass but you have to
remember the TV is largely designed for
the masses so it's going to be something
really cool that people that have not
read the books and have no idea and
maybe didn't even watch the first Game
of Thrones series could watch and pick
up easily so I'm not expecting them to
announce anything anytime soon I was
blown away that they revealed
this suit hey we have four spin-offs
we're developing one of them is actually
going to turn into a TV show but what
will happen is is that even if they have
other good ideas they just feel like
aren't the strongest they'll put them on
a shelf and they'll have their spin-off
and they'll have their idea for whatever
next spin-off is after that so unless
the world burns to the ground in the
next eight or nine years there will be
another game of Thrones spin-off after
whatever's coming next so just let me
know in the comments what do you want
them to do in what do you want them to
call it remember it'll probably be
called Game of Thrones then dot dot dot
subtitle whatever it is what's going to
happen next is there was a Star Wars
last Jedi video that I postponed and
there's some guardians of the galaxy
that I'll be posting so we'll say
congratulations to Rebecca L you're the
latest giveaway winner from last week
please private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact details you can click here for
my aria preview ed Sheeran was talking
about the scenes they share and you can
click here for more promo videos thank
you so much for watching let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight